[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر ملكي
واحييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر
امريكا تدفع نحو برميل نفط روسيه عند 70
دولارا واوروبا تسعى لوضع سقف اخر لسعر
الغاز ومدريد ترفض
في كاس العالم منتخباته اسيا تشعل البطوله
بعد انتصار السعوديه على الارجنتين
اليابان تهزموا المانيا وتهددها بالاقصاء
كعامي 2018
واعيد تركيا بعمليه بريه في سوريا
بعد التهديد يقول انه ينتظر الوقت الملائم
لدينا ايضا في العربيه 360 هذه الليله
شركات كبرى تعلق اعلاناتها على تويتر
جورنال تؤكد ان ماسك يتعرض لحمله من
اليسار
[موسيقى]
في الحرب الروسيه في الاوكرانيه اليوم
كثير من التطورات ربما ابرزها جاء من
خارجي ميدان المعركه وعلى بعد مئات
الكيلومترات في ستراسبورغ الفرنسيه حيث
صنف البرلمان الاوروبي وروسيا كدوله راعيه
للارهاب بدعوه ان الهجمات التي تشنها على
اهداف المدنيه في اوكرانيا تنتهي القانون
الدولي هي خطوه رمزيه الى حد كبير فريق
الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يوجد لديه اطار عمل
قانوني يترجم هذا القرار الى واقع اما
روسيا فكان ردها مقتضبا على لسان المتحدث
باسم خارجياتها ماريا التي اقترح التصنيفا
البرلمان الاوروبي ككيان راع للحماقه
بعد ذلك تعرض موقع البرلمان الاوروبي على
الانترنت لهجوم سيبراني اخرجه عن الخدمه
في الردود الروسيه ايضا قصف جديد عبر وابل
من الصواريخ استهدف البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
الاوكرانيه يقول عمده كياف فيتالكو ان
اجلاء الاوكرانيين من اكياس خلال الشتاء
ليس مستبعدا لعدم قدره العاصمه على توفير
الطاقه للتدفئه هي ازمه طاقه اذن تعاني
منها اوكرانيا وايضا اوروبا التي تبحث
مفوضيهتها وضع سقفا لسعر الغازي المستخدم
في التدفئه داخل دول الاتحاد ولكن دول
التكتل غيره موحده تصف اسبانيا هذه الخطه
بالمهله والمحاوله الاوروبيه للاستهزاء
بالعالم وانها ستعارض الامر بشده وهو الذي
قد تكون له ردود فعل عكسيه في الاسواق
بينما تبحث اوروبا هذه الخطه تسعى مجموعه
السبعه لتنفيذ خطه اخرى وبشكل عاجل وهي
وضعوا سقفا بسعر نفطر روسيا
[موسيقى]
لم تؤتي العقوبات الغربيه على روسيا
ثمارها كما كان مرجوا منها على ما يبدو
وبدات الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
التفكير جديا باجراءات تقيد موسكو اكثر
دبلوماسيون الاوروبي صرح بان مجموعه السبع
تدرس وضع حد اقصى لسعر النفط الروسي
المنقول بحرا يتراوح بين 65
دولارا للبرميل كما نرى اذ يناقش سفراء من
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي البالغ عددها 27
دوله هذا الاقتراح بهدف التوصل لموقف
مشترك في نهايه الامر ومن المقرر ان تبدا
مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي في الخامس
من ديسمبر بتطبيقي الحد الاقصى للسعر على
صادرات النفط الروسي المنقوله بحرا
لمعاقبه موسكو علشان انها حربا على
اوكرانيا
مسؤول كبير في وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
قال ان سقف اسعار صادرات النفط الروسيه
سيتعدل على الارجح بضع مرات في السنه وليس
بشكل شهري الهدف الاساس من الخطوه تقليل
عائده النفط لاله الحرب الروسيه مع الحفاظ
على تدفق الخام الى الاسواق العالميه ومنع
ارتفاع الاسعار من المقرر ان يبدا التطبيق
الحد الاقصى لصادرات المنتجات النفطيه
الروسيه في الخامس من فبراير المقبل لكن
للرئيس الروسي راي ايضا
[موسيقى]
اذا كانت اسعار النفط من روسيا او دول
اخرى محدوده وتم وضعه حدود سعريه مصنعه
فسيؤدي ذلك حتما الى تفاقم مناخ الاستثمار
في قطاع الطاقه العالميه ومن ثم سيؤدي الى
نقص عالميا في موارد الطاقه وسترتفع
تكلفتها وهذا اكرر سيصيب الدول الفقيره
منخفاض مخزون الاستراتيجي الامريكي ثم
انخفضت باكثر من دولار بعد ذلك تقول وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جانين والتي دفعت
باتجاه الخطوه بشده ان الهدف من الخطه هو
تقليسه صادرات الطاقه الروسيه مع تجنب
ارتفاع اسعار النفط لكن اوروبا تعاني
وتواجه ازمه ارتفاع الاسعار وازمه طاقه
خانقه اخرج التظاهرات غاضبه في شوارع مدن
اوروبيه
ستحضر مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي
واستراليا تقديمها الخدمات البحريه لشحنات
النفط الروسيه ما لم يتم بيعه النفط باقل
من سقف السعر لكنها خطه وجهه وعقبه فلا
تزال المحادثات بشان الحد الاقصى مثيره
للجدل الذي يدعو عدد من البلدان بما في
ذلك بولندا ولتانيا الى تحديد سقف اقل
كثير حول سعر الانتاج
روسيا كانت هددت بوقف البيع للدول التي
تلتزم بسعر السقف لكنه واشنطن قللت من
اهميه التهديدات الروسيه لكون موسكو لا
تستطيع ان تتوقف عن بيع نفطها على الاقل
لحلفائها تحديدا الهند والصين وقبل ان
تبدا الخطوه بدات الاستثناءات اذ قررت
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه استثناء النفط من
مشروع الطاقه الروسيه اثنين المتجه الى
اليابان من السقف السعري وكاله انباء
انباء كيودو اليابانيه افادت بان طوكيو
وشركات تجاريه اليابانيه ستحتفظ بحصص في
مشروع خلين اثنين الذي تعتبره الحكومه
مصدرا مهما لامدادات الطاقه للبلد الفقير
بالموارد اذ ان واردات النفط الروسيه شكلت
حوالي ثلاثه فاصل سته بالمئه من اجمالي
الواردات اليابانيه العام الماضي
[موسيقى]
معنى من باريس البحث الاقتصادي دكتور
دانيال ملحم اهلا بك معنا دكتور مره جديده
على شاشه العربيه لنبدا الموضوع سعر النفط
الى اي مدى باعتقادك ستنجح الخطط الغربيه
لوضع سقف سعري للنفط الروسي والى ماذا
ستلتزم البلدان حتى الحليفه منها للولايات
المتحده بذلك وهل يمكن فعلا لروسيا ان
تنفذ تهديدها بوقف المبيعات
تحيه لك يا سيدي والمشاهدين الكرام نعم
للاندر الى الواقع نوعا ما اذا كان قرار
المجموعه السابعه سوف ينجح ام لا
دعني افصل في عده نقاط النقطه الاولى نحن
نعرف ان عمليه نبتديه عن 5 ديسمبر الاتحاد
الاوروبي سوف يوقف صادرات او واردات عفوا
ان نفطر روسي لاتيه من البحر اثنين اغلب
دول الصين والهندي هي عمليه تستورد
وبخصومات كبيره جدا ثلاثه الاستثناءات
التي ذكرتها سيدي قبل قليل وهذا ما نعرف
عنه من استثناءات فيما يتعلق في النفوذ
الى
اليابان وبالتالي يمكن ان يكون هناك
استثناءات اخرى وبالتالي من سيشتري ان نفض
الباقي اليوم نحن نعرف سيدي بشكل جدي وحتى
الولايات المتحده هي تشتري النفط الروسي
عن طريق النفوس التي تباع الى
المصافي الهنديه فهو يصل الى مسافه
الهنديه وبالتالي يباع باسعار الاصوات
لتاء لك اليوم نحن عندما ننظر الى هذه
الخطوه هي الخطوه همم النوعا
اكثر ما هي خطوه عمليه ويمكن ان تنجح
عمليا لان اليوم التوقيت هو ملائم لهكذا
لهكذا ظرف لماذا لانه عمليا تنخفض الاسعار
ليس خوفا من صفوف انا برايي تنخفض الاسعار
نوعا ما اليوم لانه عمليا بعد التقارير
صندوق النقد الدولي وكافه تقرير دون ان
ندخل في ركود عالم كبير ويمكن ان يستمر
الى سنتين وبالتالي الطلب العالمي سوف
ينخفض وهنا عمليا يلعب الدور لصالح مجموعه
السبع بتحديد هذا السقف اليوم عندما نتكلم
عن ثقف 70 دولار هو السقف هجوم نوعا ما
يمكن ان يضر بالعلاقات او يمكن نوعا ما
يضر بعلاقات دول اوبك لانه تعتبر هي ثقف
هجومي لديها لانه اليوم نحن نعرف ان نفوت
هل هو يتباع ب 65 و62 دولار بالتالي 70
دولار السقف هو ليس بثقف هجومي في ما
يتعلق في في بالنسبه لروسيه انما في يتعلق
دول اوبك لماذا لان السعر العادل الدول
الاوروبيك هي 75 دولار اذا ما اذا ما
اخذنا في الاعتبار الاستثمارات اما اذا
اخذنا في الاعتبار الاستثمارات لزياده
الانتاج فتصل الى 85 دولار وبالتالي عند
وضع السقف الى الى 70 دولار تعتبر اوبك هي
المعنيه اكثر لانه اذا بدانا بروسيا يمكن
في مرحله من المراحل همم تصل الى دول
الاوبك لانه اليوم راح نتكلم عن نادي
مشترين مقابل نادي
الخطوه افهم من كلامك همم لها علاقه ابعد
من النفط الروسي
لتستهدف نفط همم دول همم يعني مهمه صانعه
قرار همم في داخل اوبيك كلاس اضافه الى
روسيا همم خاصه بعد القرارات الاخيره التي
اخذت
نعم نعم بالطبع سيدي اليوم ليست روسيه
ليست المعنيه بشكل بشكل مباشر لانه عمليه
اليوم اذا روسيا ويمكن ومن المتوقع ان
تخفف الانتاج لانه هي عمليا روسيه بكل
الحالات سوف تخافض انتاجها لعدم
امكانياتها من الانتاج بشكل كبير في
المستقبل وبالتالي تخفيض الانتاج هو اصبح
شيء لا محال منها وبالتالي تخفيض الانتاج
الروسي سوف يحصل في حاله الدول السبع
عمليا الى هذه الخطوبه بالتالي يمكن ان ان
يزيد على الاسعار ولكن عندما نتكلم باسعار
70$ وانا استمع لليوم مجموعه الصرع ان تضع
عمليا سقوف بحدود 70 دولار يمكن ان يصل
الى 75 دولار لانه لا تريد استفزاز دول
اوبيك او ما بين ال 75$ هذا انا برايي
يمكن ان تبدا ب 75$ وبالتالي عمليا خشيه
عدم استفزاز اوبك او انتظار رده فعل اوبك
وبالتالي يمكن ان تقافه هذه الاسعار
مستقبلا مع همم
دخولنا مع الركود العالمي وبالتالي عمليه
الطلعه العالميه سوف ينخفض التدريجيا ولكن
ما يع فتح في الصين عمليا اليوم تخاف دول
اوبك عفوا الدول دول غربيه خاصه الولايات
المتحده من موجه ثانيه من التضخم الناتج
عن اعاده فتح الصين اذا في حال فات فات
اعاده فتحت الصين من جديد يؤدي الى ارتفاع
الاسعار ال- ال- ال- المتقلبه هو خاصه
ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه يمكن ان يزيد الى
موجه ثانيه من التضخم وبالتالي تؤدي الى
السياسات النقديه الدخول في الشركه الاسرع
وشكل الاقصى ورفع اسعار الفائده بالشكل
الاكبر
سقف سعر الغاز هل مع الرفض الاسباني هل
تتوقع ان تصل اوروبا فعلا الى اتفاق حول
ذلك
العمليا الميكانيكيه الذي وضعتها اليوم ال
ال الهيئه الاوروبيه او الاداره الاوروبيه
اليوم خير قابله للتطبيق هي صعبه جدا هناك
شروط عمليا اذا تخطى السعر 275$ الذي هو
مرتفع للمجاهده هو مرتفع جدا
275$ وبالتالي وبالتالي اذا تخطى هذا
السعر هناك شر ثاني ان يكون الفارق بين
الا بين سعر الغاز الاوروبي مع السعر
الغاز المسال هل هناك 58$ واذا استمرت
لفتره اسبوعين عمليا سوف تستخدم هذه هذه
الميكانيكيه وهي ليست ميكانيكيه تلقائيه
واذا كان هو قائلا ان تستعلم انا براي
عمليا اليوم هي ميكانيكيه او اليه غير
قابله للتنفيذ او اذا نفذت في حالات قصوه
جدا جدا جدا وبالتالي همم هذه الخطوه هي
خلقت ميته بالنسبه لي حتى لو وافق عليها
الاتحاد الاوروبي لن تؤدي عمليا الى الى
الى الى الى تحديد او عمليا همم همم حمايه
الاتحاد الاوروبي من رفع
الاسعار في المستقبل هي خطوه دفاعيه نوعا
ما اكثر ما هي خطوه هجوميه وبالتالي هي
صعبه المنال الحل الوحيد بدات اليوم تطفو
بعض المعلومات عن الاسعار هي الشراء
المشترك لالمانيا وفرنسا في عقود طويله
الاجل عن طريق عن طريق النرويج وهنا يبدا
عمليا بدايه الحل في اوروبا ويكون هذا
الهادي العقود تستهدف عمليه الانتاج
الكهرباء وهكذا تستطيع اوروبا عمليان تنفس
السعداء وخاصه في متعلق انتاج الطاقه
التي تستهلك القطاعات الصناعيه وبالتالي
المانيا تستطيع النوع ما همم الموا- ما
بين السياساتها الداخليه لانه كان ازمه
سياسيه داخليه في المانيا
سياسات التحول نحو البيئه الاوربيه شكرا
جزيلا همم على هذه القراءه همم الباحث
الاقتصادي دكتور دانيال من باريس تحياتي
اليك
اذا انت تقول طلبنا من المانيا
التي عرضناها التي عرضتها علينا الى
اوكرانيا يعني الكثير من الجدل حول هذا
الموضوع في السابق مع الموقف الامريكي انا
ذاك يبدو انه في تغير وكاله الطاقه الذريه
تقول محطه نوويه باوكرانيا تعمل بمولدات
طاقه بعد قطع الكهرباء ومع الخطط الغربيه
عسكريه على الارض تسير اوكرانيا نحو تحرير
المزيد من اراضيها بعد انسحاب روسيا من
خرسان تقاتل القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه
الان الروس في الجزر والمستنقعات الى
الجنوب الغربي من مدينه خرسان في مصنع
لتحرير شبه جزيره كونغرس
نتابع واياكم مع شبه الجزيره تلك التي
تكتسب اهميه استراتيجيه بسبب وقوعها عند
مصاب نهر النيبرو تحديدا عند التقائه
بالبحر الاسود يتركز القتال في كندر على
الضفه الشرقيه لنهر التي تتمتع قادره
طبيعيه ساحره لكنها ستكون محوريه في
المرحله التاليه من حرب التحرير
الاوكرانيه سيطرت روسيا على شبه الجزيره
في يونيو الماضي في واحده من اخر تقدماتها
الملحوظه هناك في الجنوب قبل ان تجبرها
كيف على التراجع والتحول للدفاع تسمح
السيطره على شبه الجزيره لروسيا بابقاء
قوه اعمق في البحر الاسود وحراسه الطرق
المؤديه الى موانئ في ميكو لايف وخيرسون
وحمايه قواتها في شبه جزيره القرد اذا
استولت اوكرانيا على سبيت فانها ستضع خطوط
امداد روسيه التي تمتد شمالا من شبه جزيره
القرم تحت مرمى انظمه الاسلحه الاوكرانيه
قال فيتاليكم رئيس الاداره العسكريه في
منطقه ميكولايف ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحرز
تقدما في كندر سبت وسيطرت بالفعل على بلده
اوتشاكيف على بعد اقل من خمسه كيلومترات
من شبه الجزيره بينما قلم مدونين عسكريون
روس ان القوات الروسيه تصدت الهجمات على
شبه جزيره كنبرز وفقما نقلته صحيفه
نيويورك
[موسيقى]
مشكله اخرى
بعض اقاليم البلاد نداءات لانهاء تعبئه
القوات المستمره رغم اعلان وزاره الدفاع
انتهائها ففي احدث مؤشر على تصاعد ارسل
مسؤولو جمهوريه كاريليا وهي منطقه شمال
غربروسيا على الحدود مع فنلندا خطابا
لبوتن يحضه على اصدار مرسوم يمنع الجيش من
مواصله تعبئه الجاريه بسبب اثاره السلبيه
على المجتمع كتبت ايليا سالبه نوفا وهي
عضو في الجمعيه في الجمعيه التشريعيه في
كاريليا ان التعبئه تمثل مصدر قلق متزايدا
للقصر الروسيه ومجموعات العمل والعديد من
الناس يعانون من مشاكل صحيه اضافت ان
التصاريح والخطب العامه الصادره عن
السلطات العسكريه ليست اجراءات معياريه
بالتالي ليس لها قوه قانونيه
تاتي الرساله بعد ما اتهمت اوكرانيا روسيا
ببدا تعبئه سريه لتجنيد المزيد من
المواطنين الروس في شبه جزيره القرم
المنطقه التي ضمتها روسيا من اوكرانيا في
عام 2014 هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ذكرت ان
اجراءات التعبئه السريه في صفوف القوات
الروسيه ما زالت جاريه في شبه جزيره القرم
في من نفى الكرملين قائلا انه لا توجد
مناقشات بشان تعبئه ثانيه او سريه
الجيش
بعد يوم من تصريحات الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان باقتراب العمليه العسكريه البريه
في سوريا يعود اليوم ويقول ان تركيا ستطلق
هذه العمليه في الوقت المناسب ربما تاتي
تصريحات بسبب ما اعلنت روسيا وامريكا عن
ضروره التجنب هذه العمليه لكن في الاثناء
تقول تركيا انها قصفت جوا نحو 500 هدف
للمقاتلين الاكراد في شمال العراق وسوريا
منذ الاحد الماضي ولكن دون توهلا على
الارض
داخليا وعلى الارض يهتز شمال الغربي في
تركيا بسبب زلزال يضرب تلك المناطق
اما خارجيا وعلى الحدود الجنوبيه الشرقيه
تهتز الارض شمالي سوريا والعراق لكن بسبب
الضربات الجويه التركيه هناك
العمليه التي وصفت بالاكبر والاشمل
والاكثر فاعليه في شمالي العراق وسوريا
واسفرت عن تحييد 254 مسلحا واصابت 401
هدفا وزاره الدفاع التركيه
[موسيقى]
والطائرات بدون طياره ليست سوى البدايه
وعيد بمزيد من الضربات بموازاه القصف
الجويه والمدفعيه الى زحف القوات البريه
وفي الوقت المناسب بحسب الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان وذلك ما يخشاه النظام السوري
الذي تتزايد مخاوفه من تكرار الرئيس
التركي تحضيراته من ان جيشه قد ينفذ
تواغلا بريا جديدا في سوريا وهو امر
تعاهدت القوات الكرديه المدعومه من
الولايات المتحده بالتصدي لها مقابل حتى
روسيا لتركيا بالتحلي كابتنفس والانتناعي
عن شنه هجوم بري واسع النطاق في سوريا
فيما تثير الضربات التركيه التوتر مع
النظام السوري ايضا اضافه الى ان تلك
الضربات التركيه اصابت مواقع لجيش النظام
السوري اسفرت عن مقتل واصابه جنود ضربات
قد تلغي الاتفاق الضني في الخصومه ضد
الاكراد السوريين بين انقره ودمشق دمشق
التي تعارض سيطره الاكراد على نحو ثلث
اراضي البلاد ومنها الشرق الغني بالنفط
لتظلم واقع الاكراد في الشمال السوري كما
العراقي ايضا بؤره لصراع مشتعل على الدواء
[موسيقى]
اعلنت شركه اوديه المصنعه للسيارات
الالمانيه وقف كل انشطتها على موقع تويتر
على خلفيه استحواذ ايلون ماسك الى ذلك
اعلنت مجموعه فولكس فاجن للسيارات
الالمانيه انها ستوقف اعلانات كل الشركات
تابعه لها كسيارات سيات و لمبرجيني و
بنتلي ودوكاتي وبورش وقال صحيفه واشنطن
بوستن الثلث المعلنين الكبار في تويتر
اوقفوا اعلاناتهم خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
كان ايضا
حقوقيه بانتهاك اتفاق معه يساعد على
استمرار الاعلانات على تويتر
[موسيقى]
استحواذ الين ماسك على تويتر خطوه مهمه
على طريق ضمان حريه التعبير عالميا ولكن
بحسب صحيفه جورنال الصحيفه قالت ان شركات
التقنيه الاكبر في العالم اوجدت انماطا
معينه من الخطاب واذا لم يتم الالتزام
بهذه الانماط فسيكون الحظر هو البديل خلال
هذه الفتره حاولت العديد من المدافعين عن
حريه التعبير حاولوا شقه طريقهم لكنهم
تعرضوا للقمع من عمالقه التكنولوجيا
المهيمنه وحاول البعض ايجاد من السطات
بديله مثل بارلر وتروس سوشيال كبديل عن
تويتر ومجددا وجهه وبحضر التطبيق على
متاجر التطبيقات
التعبير خاصه
اكثر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي نشاطا في
العالم فكره ماسك عن عدم وجود قيود على
التع قبلت باراء متضاربه بين من اعتبره
انجازا ومن اعتبره يفتح الباب لخطاب
الكراهيه اشارت الصحيفه ايضا الى القيود
التي وضعتها شركات التكنولوجيا على
التعبير خاصه خلال ذروه جائحه كورونا مكان
له تاثير حقيقي على السياسه والطب
والادراك العام للشعب
موقع تويتر
مثل ما يشاء خاصه وان القوانين الامريكيه
تتيح للشركات الخاصه ان تضع قوانينها
الخاصه
يرمي حجرا في بركه عمالقه التقنيه وقد
يثير نقاشا حقيقيا حول حريات التعبير
اضافه الى انه قد يواصل فتح الفساد
والانتفاخ داخل شركات التكنولوجيا والطرق
التي تستخدمها لكتم الاصوات المعارضه
لملاك هذه من الصاد وهم في اغلبهم من
اليسار في الولايات المتحده جهودك بحسبنر
مجرد مشروع راس مالي قد يكون ناجحا او لا
من وجهه نظر اقتصاديه لكن من وجهه نظر
اجتماعيه فقد بدا بالفعل بخرق السقف الذي
وضعته وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
معنى من سامسونج
من موظفين حاليين او سابقين مع التطورات
الاخيره بخصوص تويتر
تحيه لك طاهر موضوع الاعلانات وموضوح حريه
التعبير وتبادل الاتهامات مع تويتر
والجهات الاخرى كرات الثلج في الحقيقه
تكبر وتكبر كل يوم الثابت وحيد حتى الان
ان الشركه هنا التي اقف امامها في سان
فرانسيسكو مازال القائمون عليها يرفضون
التحدث الى وسائل الاعلام اليوم قمت
بمحاوله جديده وحاولت التواصل مع احد فيها
ودخلت الى همم الى قرب البوابه الرئيسيه
لكن كالمعتاد قبل همم برجال الامن حول
المكان طلبوا مني عدم التسجيل وعدم احضار
الكاميرا همم سالتهم هل يمكنني التواصل مع
احد قال يمكنك ان تدق الباب وترى اذا كان
سيتواصلون معك وبالفعل هذا ما فعلته همم
اقتربت همم من همم البوابه الرئيسيه لشركه
تويتر حاولت تتواصل مع الموظفين لكنهم
عندما عرفوا انني همم صحه صحفي رفضه
الحديث مع عكاه ما هو المعتاد هم لا يعطون
تصريحات شركه التويتر تلتزم بالصمت حتى
الان في ظل ما يحدث همم طبعا نحن نريد ان
نتحدث لنعرف ما يجري ولاسيما انه مؤخرا
لهم ماس كما نقل عنه اعلن طاهر انتهاء
مرحله همم
الاقالات وبدا مرحله التوظيف نريد ان نعرف
كيف سيكون هذا التوظيف
لانه قال بانه سيركز سيعطي الاولويه ل همم
المهندسين ولموظفين همم المبيعات ولكن همم
حتى الان همم الموظفون داخل المؤسسه الذين
بقوا وهم عددهم بالمناسبه 2700 بحسب اخر
التقديرات همم لا يريدون التحدث هناك خوف
عندما يسال اي موظف يخرج من هذا الباب
نقول هل انت حتى لو كان من تويتر يرفض
الحديث منوي الكره انه يعمل في تويتر هناك
نشعر بان هناك خوف والان داخل هذه المؤسسه
كما علمنا بعضهم بعض من من اقيل اقيل
لانهم عبروا عن رايهم على تويتر او عن همم
على اي وسيله التواصل الاجتماعي لهذا الان
الباقون ملتزمون بالصمت نحاول التواصل مع
اخرين ولكن من الصعبه الوصول لام حاليا
نحن نحاول دائما ذلك ولكن همم الامر ليس
بهذه السهوله بالنسبه للاعلانات طاهر
بالفعل همم الشركات الكبرى الان تواجه
ضغوط من الجمعيات همم المدنيه والتي تدافع
الحقوق ومن ناشطين كسر يعتبرون ان اله
الناس من خلال ما يقول بانه حريه التعبير
هو يسمح للمتطرفين ويسمح بانتشار خطاب
الكراهيه وايضا الخطاب المعادي للساميه
كما يقولون لهذا هم يدفعون ويضغطون على
الشركات الكبرى وقف الاعلان في تويتر
في المقابل كما انا ماسك التهمهم يتهمون
ماسك بانه لم يلتزم معهم كان هناك اجتماع
سابق في بدايه هذا الشهر قال لهم ماسك انه
سي ينشا مجلس لمراقبه المحتوى لمحاربه اا
خطاب الكراهيه او لوقف خطاب الكراهيه
ومعالجته ولكنه عندما اعاده تفعيل حساب
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب هذه الجمعيات
وهؤلاء النشطون اعتبروا ان ذلك همم عدم
التزام بالوعد الذي اعطاهم اياه المساعده
فقط
في نفس الموضوع الذي تتحدث عنه يسال
متابعيه هل على تويتر ان همم يعني همم
يقوم بعفو عام عن كل الحسابات همم
الموقوفه اذا لم تخرق القانون او اذا لم
تتورط في اي همم رسائل الكترونيه مزوره
فظيعه همم وهناك الكثير من التصويت على
هذه التغريده بانتظار ان يفعل ذلك ربما ما
يدري كما فعل من قبل في حسابات معينه
هنا النقطه طاهر الجمعيات الحقوقيه
والنشطون لا يعتبرون ان هذا التصويت ايه
يعكس راى الامريكيين ولا يعتبرون انه يعكس
ايضا الشفافيه كان بعضهم بالشفافيه
بالتعامل مع هكذا مواضيع هم يرفضون هذا
التصويت هم لا يعتبرونه شفافيه هنا الجدل
الكبير الان بين مصر من جهه وبين الناشطين
والجمعيات المدافعه عن همم حقوقيه المدافع
عن عن الحقوق المدنيين التي تحارب كما
تقول خطاب الكراهيه وخطاب معادلات ال
اسلاميه همم هذا هذا هو الرفض المتبادل
بين الاثنين وعدم همم يعني في ظل رفض كما
قلنا رفض شركه تويتر التواصل مع الصحفيين
لا بشكل تصريحات رسميه احنا ما نسمعه عن
تويتر الان هو تصريحات لبعض الموظفين
السابقين او الذين اقيلوا همم يتحدثون ب
همم بالكثير من الاحيان بشرطها لا تذكر
اسمائهم الحقيقيه او من بعض الموظفين
الذين ما زالوا يعملون في الداخل ولكن
يرفضون
لا في صحن اسمها ايه لكن لا يوجد بيان
رسمي من تويتر حول حول الموضوع هذا يزيد
من الغموض ويزيد ايضا من التشكيك من قبل
الناشطين ومن قبل الجمعيات الحقيقيه نسيم
انماس كما يقولون هم بانه لم يستشيرهم
مثلا بموضوع همم اعاده تفعيل حساب ضونال
ترامب وعدد من الشخصيات التي يصفون هذاها
متطرفه
لنفعل ما يريد انما غير كثيرا ايضا في
اولويات وسائل الاعلام العالميه وهمم مثل
الكثير من نشاطاتك اليوميه انت كما انتقلت
من امام المؤسسات الرسميه الامريكيه الى
امام تويتر وربما لاحقا الى مؤسسات وسائل
تواصل اخرى وربما هذا النوع من التغطيات
سيسود في الفتره ماء من الزمن من سان
فرانسيسكو مراسل العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه المعلومات
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا
الجمهوريون يبداون خطه عسلي بيضا ويستهلون
الطريق لوزير الامن الداخلي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد من العام المقبل نقطه
بدايه لتحقيقات بشان اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن عندما يتسلم الجمهوريون
منصه قياده مجلس النواب الدوره الثامنه
عشر بعد المئه للكونجرس الامريكي قد يطغى
عليها تشكيل لجان تحقيق مع عددا من مسؤولي
الاداره بعدما وعد بعض من الجمهوريين بذلك
اذا قالت اليهم اغلبيه الغرفه الادنى من
الكونجرس الملف الاول سيكون مع ملف الهجره
غير القانونيه عبر الحدود الجنوبيه
للولايات المتحده والذي كان محوره اهتمام
للناخبنا الجمهوريين خلال الانتخابات
النصفيه فوضى الحدود بحسب الجمهوريين يرى
مراقبنا انها ستكون منطلقا للحزب
الجمهوريه للوصول الى بدي محاكمه باعتباره
اكبر مسؤول في الاداره بحسب رئيس المرتقب
لمجلس النواب كافي
4 2
4 يوتيوب
مكارثي طلب وزير الامن الداخلي اليخاندرو
مايوركاس بالاستقاله والا واجه اسابيع من
التحقيقات امام لجان الكونجرس ومن مدينه
الباسو والحدوديه مع المكسيك قال مكارثي
ان الحدود شهدت في عهد مايوركاس دخول
اعداد كبيره من من هم على لوائح مراقبه
الارهاب اضافه الى مرور كميات قياسيه من
المخدرات شمالا باتجاه الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
اكشن
وزير الامن الداخلي
قال انه لا يخطط لمغادره منصبه بحسب بيان
للوزاره قبل التحقيقات المتوقعه معه امام
الكونجرس ذات الاغلبيه الجمهوريه بدوره
اعتبر البيت الابيض ان الجمهوريين ليست
لديهم خطه لتحسين الوضع وكاله المتحدثه
باسم البيت الابيض كريم جون بيار ان
الجمهوريين يقومون فقط بممارسه الاعب
سياسيه على حد قورها لكن في الكواليس تحدث
مسؤول في البيت الابيض لتقى بمحامي
الاداره الامريكيه مع مسؤولين وزاره الامن
الداخليه للبدائي في الاستعداد للتحقيق مع
الوزير ما يوركاست فيما يتوقع ان يكون
واحدا من عده تحقيقات متعلقه باداره بيدن
الحديث في الجانب الجمهوري عن ازمه الهجره
امر تدركه الاداره وايضا وزاره الامن
الداخلي عندما طلب مايوركاس من مدير هيئه
الحدود والجمارك الاستقاله قبل ايام وكما
هو الحال مع الوزير مايوركاس رفض المسؤول
كريسماس الاستقاله رغم ابلاغه بانه
سيطردوا ان لم يغادر بمفرده الى ان ردخ
مانجو ماغنوس للامر الواقع وفي وقت لاحق
اصدر البيت الابيض بيانا يشكر فيه مجلس
على مسيرته المهنيه التي استمرت 40 عاما
في الخدمه العامه
[موسيقى]
يوم في العربيه 360 من دوله تشيلي في
امريكا الجنوبيه وهي
لثوران بركان فيلاريكا جنوب البلاد والذي
اصبح نشيطا مؤخرا يقع البركان على جبل
ارتفاعه لاكثر من
2800 متر وتظهر الصور الملتقطه من بعيد
وهج الحمم خلال الليل السلطات حذرت السكان
من انفجار كبير محتمل للبركان كما عطلت
تحليق الطائرات فوق تلك المنطقه
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 لرئيسه وزراء
اسكتلندا نيكولاس توجن وذلك بعد انقضت
المحكمه العليا في بريطانيا بعدم جواز
اجراء استفتاء الانفصال الستوتلندا عن
المملكه المتحده دون موافقه البرلماني
البريطاني تقول سيرجيو انها لن تتخلى عن
مسار الاستفتاء وستواصل السعي لتحقيق
الانفصال مشيره الى انها ستبحث عن وسائل
اخرى قانونيه تسهل على الاستقلالنديين
الحصول على الاستفتاء اعتبرت رئيسه وزراء
اسكتلندا انها لو فازت في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه المقبله فذلك يعتبر استفتاء
فعليا من الاسكتلنديين على رغبتهم في
الانفصال عن بريطانيا
فيديو اليوم في العربيه 360 هو من الصين
التي اعادت فرده قيود فيروس كورونا من
مدينه تشنكشو الامر الذي اثار احتجاجات من
العمال في مصنع ايفون في المدينه حاولت
سلطات حجر العمال الذين احتجوا وحتى
مكاميرات المراقبه في المصنع وذلك رفضا
للظروف السيئه للعزل ونقص الغذاء وبسبب
فصلهم عن المجتمع بشكل كامل الاحتجاجات
اندلعت في مصانع اخرى في المدينه وشهدت
مواجهات بين العمال والقوه
[موسيقى]